[Música]
olá
é eu vim compartilhar um cão um
pouquinho disso com vocês hoje
vocês já olharam para uma flor é o você
simplesmente acrescentar um nome a essa
flor chamaram de flores
sempre que a gente olha para uma flor a
gente categoriza a como uma flor a gente
coloca qualidades nessa flor né é
vermelha é bonita feia né e será que
realmente a gente olha para essa flor é
a gente
naturalmente no curso da nossa vida
a gente vem criando é uma espécie de
lente em interface com a realidade
quanto mais novos a gente a bebês
crianças a gente tem uma lente de
fininha e essa lente vai aumentando vai
aumentando até chegar na fase adulta né
onde ela tem uma certa espessura
toda a nossa interação com a realidade
se dá por meio dessa lente então dentro
de si
a gente pode colocar uma caixinha nossa
dentro dessa caixinha transparente é que
a gente faz essa interface com a
realidade é onde estão todas as nossas
experiências dos nossos conhecimentos às
nossas dúvidas e tudo isso não vai sendo
construído desde a barriga da nossa mãe
chegar no dia de hoje
então toda vez quem se depara com alguma
experiência ou com algum fato nexe
coloca nossa frente a gente faz um
filtro por toda essa caixinha até chegar
na concepção que a gente faz daquilo que
ocorreu
geralmente a gente busca referências no
nosso passado né pra reagir
aquilo que é posto à nossa frente só que
isso é pra responder algumas perguntas
né é justamente isso que impede a gente
vê a verdadeira natureza das coisas é
obviamente não é o pensamento ele criou
coisas fantásticas
a gente pode perceber no dia de hoje
stoxx que vieram até agora são
expressões do pensamento humano
da mesma forma o mesmo pensamento criou
o extremismo do estado islâmico né e
então a gente percebe é que esse
pensamento
ele é é pode ser muito genial muito
benéfico a humanidade é também muito
descritivo né então o pensamento humano
ele é ótimo para a gente começar a
questionar o que está no nosso entorno
é só por ele é que a gente começa a se
perguntar por que estou aqui quem somos
nós porque a sociedade é como é a gente
também busca pelo pensamento responder a
essas coisas mas o pensamento ele é
limitado
ele é um reflexo ele é um espelho da
nossa realidade
na verdade ele tenta construir uma
imagem da realidade só que ele é
limitado pela linguagem então nunca ele
vai conseguir é passar a realidade de
fato ele sempre vai ser limitado então
tudo o que a gente pensa todas as nossas
idéias
elas não são a realidade de fato um dos
grandes problemas que acontece é a nossa
crença de que o pensamento é a realidade
e esse é um dos maiores equívocos que a
gente faz a nossa vida
é justamente quando tudo
silencia dentro da gente quando a gente
abandona todas as nossas concepções e
abandona todas as nossas idéias que a
gente consegue ter acesso a um estado a
uma operação cerebral uma forma não é do
cérebro perea muito diferente dessa
habitual que a gente vem construindo
desde a nossa infância então a gente
praticamente é treinado para que o
cérebro funciona dessa forma
então justamente quando tudo silencia
dentro da gente que a gente abandona
todo esse conteúdo é que a gente pode
experience a realidade diretamente e
pela primeira vez é possível que a gente
olhe para uma flor sem nenhum pensamento
ocorrendo
a gente percebe se utiliza da fúria
a sutileza da pétala a sutileza do
perfume
a gente sabe que o espinho da flor
machuca
só que a gente não precisa ficar falando
a gente não precisa dizer a que linda
flor meu deus altura deveria tê lá em
casa não é necessário a gente pode
presenciar essa flor diretamente o
pensamento ele também se torna então
plástico na é quase que como um jardim
né ele serve e ela tem a sua função de
agente transitar no mundo humano
por sinal o mundo humano que a gente
vive a sociedade que a gente vive
ela é uma construção do pensamento
humano
então se ela é uma construção do
pensamento humano
ela também pode ser modificado
e ela não é a realidade e se todas a
gente pode perceber nas suas culturas
que funciona de uma forma
sociedade funciona de outra forma né
então esse pensamento né
ele tem uma função e de transição do
mundo né eu minha ação é no mundo é ali
que eu consigo modificar o meu entorno
então é necessário que a gente
desenvolva todas as nossas capacidades
é necessário que a gente desenvolva o
intelecto que a gente desenvolva um
sensível não é que a gente desenvolva o
raciocínio crítico necessário porque
isso são ferramentas de ação do mundo
mas não são eles a realidade a realidade
ela se dá quando a gente ultrapassa essa
barreira do pensamento
então é onde eu percebo né e onde surge
também toda a paz toda calma toda a
alegria a felicidade ela funciona nesse
terreno
quando não existe mais eu e o outro mas
eu e o objeto né a gente entra nesse
estado que a todo o nosso pensamento
todos os nossos conteúdos ele se
assentam na ilha uma luz uma luz se
manifesta
nesse local é uma forma de ver
completamente diferente é nesse estado
mental que a gente não odeia que a gente
não se quer desejar o mal a ninguém
é nesse estado que é onde a paz ea
felicidade acontece vocês podem perceber
né agora mesmo em vocês
o emaranhado de pensamentos e de
conceitos que a gente vive
esses conceitos e pensamentos como eu
coloquei ele são necessárias mas eles
têm o selo local
eles têm quando funcionar então quando a
gente se depara com alguém que a gente
olha nos olhos de alguém
procurem
escutar verdadeiramente abandonem seus
preconceitos abandonem os seus conceitos
a forma com que a gente vive hoje a
gente vê vi com construções de imagem
eu faço uma imagem de vocês vocês farão
uma imagem minha aqui mesmo nesse
auditório agora tem cerca de 100 imagens
minhas formados na mente de vocês
todas elas rodeados dos conceitos e
preconceitos e experiências do passado
de vocês quando a gente abandona tudo
isso a gente tem a chance ea
oportunidade de ver cada um
verdadeiramente às vezes quando a gente
abandona é a primeira vez que a gente vê
a face de alguém tinha teve uma
experiência muito interessante uma vez
que a minha mãe que eu tive plena a
sensação de que eu tinha olhado ela pela
primeira vez eu estava despido de tudo o
que eu tinha construído até então eu
olhei para ela e vi ela pela primeira
vez
isso é muito bonito eu gostaria que
todos tivessem alguma vez na vida a
oportunidade de ver as coisas em um
filtro pela frente
o interessante de estudo é que cada um
de vocês tem isso
isso não é de ninguém e só de todos
ele está aí para ser acessado é um
direito de cada um de vocês né baixa
gente aprender acessar a gente consegue
às vezes em alguma experiência ou outra
acessar estado
mas a gente não se dá conta disso
então como a gente está tão condicionado
ao estado anterior de funcionamento a
gente até estranha nesse estado que a
gente assessor né ele estar disponível
basta a gente aprender acessar
eu tenho uma simples mensagem pra deixar
aqui pro final
apreciem as suas vidas
a nossa vida é rápida é curta
tudo o que a gente conseguir fazer para
apreciar as a nossa vida para vivê la
com intensidade viver presente estejam
presentes na vida né que é muito natural
a gente está no local está com quem e na
verdade nossa mente está em outro lugar
então tentem viver a sua vida nas suas
vidas intensamente e viver intensamente
significa viver presente aqui e agora a
gente é nesse aqui agora é onde tem a
oportunidade de se tornar o amor se
tornar a paz é essas coisas elas não são
dependentes
elas simplesmente são então quando nós
nos tornamos o amor
nós nos tornamos a paz a gente
simplesmente é meu desejo que todos
sejam um amor a paz e que sejam bem
também
obrigado
[Aplausos]